quand j'entends par les sénateurs je me
demande s'il connaît bien le projet
parce que comme engrais parce que ça se
passe pas du tout ça c'est pas ça se
passe pas du tout comme ça c'est c'est
ça c'est dans le meilleur des mondes et
comme nous sommes ce soir dans le
meilleur des mondes déjà comment
dirais-je qu'on vous dise elle marine et
iberdrola bas iberdrola s'est
etc européen mais il faut regarder les
casseroles qu'il traîne la réputation
nous on a joué franchement on a
travaillé avec au début avant 2017 avec
une équipe de l'équipe je dirais elle
elle marine
mais depuis 2007 on est l'équipe
iberdrola est là aujourd'hui c'est plus
des gens qu'on négocie si on nous envoie
des mercenaires quand on parle de vous
parler des travaux qui ont commencé en
mai
si vous d'objets bien être au courant un
peu de ce qui s'est passé à saint
nazaire et bien le programme des travaux
de saint nazaire les discussions ont
duré trois ans
dans le parc de saint brieuc il n'y a
pas une seule réunion pour préparer le
chantier pour avoir des accords d époque
des certaine époque pour travailler plus
ou moins commencé avril mai juin discuté
par rapport au travail des bateaux ça il
ya eu aucune discussion
normalement elle m'a lll marine
iberdrola doit fournir un comment
dirais-je un programme trois mois avance
au service de l'état ça n'a jamais été
fait jamais
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses comme ça
qu'ils n'ont pas c'est pour ça que nous
nous sommes en colère c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on est rentrés rond
justice depuis le mois de juillet par an
[Musique]